hey youtubers it's Charlie I finally got
a chance to see Fantastic Four hopefully
you guys will see it sometime this
weekend because it is a really good
example of when a good movie goes bad
what does that mean well they have a lot
of parts of a good movie but they don't
have the whole movie the actual the
running time is only a hundred minutes
long that's an hour and 40 minutes just
by comparison Avengers age of Ultron was
almost like two and a half hours maybe a
little bit longer than that so when
you're sitting in the theater about
two-thirds of the way through the movie
you start to feel like you're getting a
lost you're like I don't understand how
the characters are getting to these
moments like why does this character
hate this other character why is Doctor
Doom going so crazy I you know I don't I
don't get it it's just all those moments
are missing from the movie so in missing
them we get to our train wreck the movie
actually is in a train wreck but I just
I love the fact that Thomas the Tank
Engine has been sitting on deck for the
last couple weeks just waiting for
something like this that being said
there are a lot of things to like about
this movie
they have great actors they they picked
a lot of great drama actors for these
comic book characters but the movie is
missing so much character development so
many of those like special scenes where
you learn why the characters act and
make decisions the way that they do that
all of their talents are wasted you
could resurrect Shakespeare to write you
the most amazing story ever but if you
cut giant chunks of it out it's not
gonna seem like a very great story just
like I said in the last couple of
Fantastic Four videos I've done they
were going for more of the sci-fi
approach of The Ultimates comic and the
problem is is that even though it kind
of starts out that way you really don't
think about the stuff that's missing
until you get to like that two-thirds
point through the movie when they're
building towards the climax when it's
like you're getting ready for like the
big final battle and you're like wait a
minute how do how do we get here so fast
it seems like just a couple minutes ago
they got their power like why are they
all in the middle of this battle royale
because this is my non-spoilery review
I'm not gonna get into like really
specific moments I know a lot of you are
asking about something that sounded like
a big DC reference towards the end of
the film I'll address that in my Easter
Egg video but here's my prognosis for
the Fantastic Four as a franchise what I
think will end up happening is is Fox
will quietly just put this on the shelf
and try again
with a different cast in like four to
six years
the reboot cycle for franchises has
accelerated drum
matically and if fox can get its
deadpool franchise up and going then I
don't think that Fantastic Four is gonna
be as big a priority like it won't be as
big a deal for them to leave it on the
shelf for a couple more years they're
not quite to the point with their x-men
franchise where they can do an infinity
war type movie where you can just stuff
all kinds of crazy characters in because
that would be perfect for Fantastic Four
Reed Richards at his core works best in
situations like that if you ever read
Marvel's infinity it was kind of in the
lead-up to Secret Wars he works
perfectly in situations where the world
is ending but this is like the first
movie it's the origin story you can't
elevate things to that level right away
you can't go from like 0 to 60 and
that's kind of what happens in the film
so that's why you're seeing a lot of the
weird reactions from people going to see
it it's not offensively bad it's just
that they tried to do too much into
little amount of time there's a lot of
talk behind the scenes about josh trank
the director fighting with the producers
about different cuts of the film
supposedly he had like a completely
different cut of the film that was
longer that he thought was a lot better
last year but the studio overruled him I
don't know anything about that if that's
true or not it sounds like behind the
scenes there was a lot of arguing as to
like what kind of movie they wanted this
to be if you go back and you watch the
original fantastic four movies - what
the one with Chris Evans Captain America
Human Torch those played way more for
comedy so I think that they wanted to
take this in a much more serious
direction in Deadpool is gonna be like
the comedy franchise but there are times
when this film feels so depressing like
you really you really don't get the
thrilling moments that you get from a
lot of the Marvel films I don't know if
they cut out a lot of like the really
small character jokes but because you
don't get a lot of those character
interactions it bleeds the movie of a
lot of its heart if the buzz behind the
franchise and the actors was a little
bit more I'd say it's a be interesting
to see them show up in an x-men film but
I think most people are gonna walk away
from this feeling like it's not the
right fit like these characters this
universe is not the right fit for a big
ridiculous comic book team-up movie
movies like that need to be way more fun
and this is just like way too serious so
really like the biggest thumbs down that
I have for the movie are the tone the
story and the editing but I give them a
giant thumbs up to what they did
visually like I feel like this version
of the thing looks better than the
classic version
I call it classic but like the last
version of the thing and I feel like the
way that they express their powers look
really good they just there were a lot
of missing moments like a lot of the
really fun montage moments the film
lacks a certain sense of excitement
especially after like the first half of
the film I feel like you just you can't
go into the last act being super
depressed without having like something
to boost you up in the movie just
doesn't have that like ego into the
final moment of the film and it just
doesn't feel fun and who wants to pay to
sit through a movie that's not fun
unless it's for a class and your teacher
said that they would fail you if you
didn't watch it so it's gonna be really
fascinating talking to people especially
with you guys in the comments about like
what didn't work about this film and
maybe what that Josh Trank cut looked
like I'm actually fascinated by that too
like what is the Josh Trank cut of
Fantastic Four and is it is much better
as he thought it was one curious thing
to note is that when Marvel is making
its movies a lot of them get made in the
editing Bay whenever they shoot scenes
they'll just do a crazy number of takes
and just shoot them in all kinds of
different ways especially with actors
like Robert Downey jr. that tend to tend
to riff a little bit more go little off
script then they stitch it together in
the editing Bay and turn it into a real
movie so Fantastic Four is a really
great example of how important editing
is to a movie and how bad editing can
destroy your story a really good
comparison for this movie would be
Punisher war zone if you don't remember
that that was the last Punisher movie
they released in theaters it was
terrible it was so bad now it was bad
for some of the same reasons but there
were also a lot of other things going on
in that film like a lot of the
performances were just just terrible and
I feel like all the actors in Fantastic
Four are totally solid like they're all
amazing actors it's really just the
missing scenes that destroy the film
Toby Kebbell is a great actor but he
almost feels like he's not in the movie
so at the end of the day I'll say it yet
this movie is very bad but it's not
offensively bad I'm not mad at it for
being bad it is a lot of fun to see
really bad movies but usually you want
to know that it's a bad movie when you
go to see it like wet hot American
summer you know TV series on Netflix
maybe they could blame it on the
super-skrull because that did come out
of the Fantastic Four comics so yeah
that's that's who will blame for this
super scroll the super scroll is the one
that edited the movie so while you guys
wait for me to post Fanta
six-four Easter eggs you can click here
for my Deadpool QA and you can click
here to watch the Deadpool trailer again
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you